well let's let's talk about some of the
good news and what this means we have
the story from cnbc elon musk expected
to serve as temporary twitter ceo after
a deal closes he also raised an
additional seven billion dollars from
friends so we'll start there
this sounds like really good news i like
elon musk right he's going to be the ceo
so he's going to be able to go in with
his own bare hands and start cleaning
things up firing people it also means
parag agrowall is out as soon as this
deal is done and by the way when they
say temper they're like elon is going to
temporarily be the ceo until he kills
himself or dies of mysterious
circumstances oh no
god oh i have a feeling he wants to get
in there make some specific changes
listen to a bunch of people and then if
you see someone he thinks is more
qualified he'll let them start executing
for him but but here's where it's also
interesting
he raised some money
i think 1.9 billion of the money he
raised came from that saudi prince who
previously said he was not okay with the
deal
so the new conspiracy theory apparently
i don't know what you look this up ian
elon musk was wearing a jacket at the
met gala that said new world order on
the back but in white embroidery on a
white jacket so you couldn't really see
it
you want to look at that
this is from investmentwatchblog.com
is it let me see if i can find it as
well yeah
bloomberg confirms elon is a young
global leader for klaus schwab wef great
reset this is the title from
investmentwatch.com
from april i think this might be fake
news it's a while ago oh no okay here we
go like almost a month three weeks ago
it could be i mean this is this grimes
that wasn't this yeah this is this is
old
what is that photo there's an old photo
but the 2018 met gala is a 2018 okay
that says new world or well there you go
yeah so he was wearing it says novus
ordo seclorum meaning new world order on
the back well his his takes are
suspiciously based you know because it's
all of it's like the red meat for what
we want to hear you're like oh you're
calling out big pharma oh you're calling
out all of these people or you're
replying to cerno
you know it's
what's going on it was over tonight
so you have this wave of populism and
they're resisting it they're trying
everything to censor it and shut it down
no matter what they do they can't win so
they say okay we need a ringer someone
who's gonna flank the populists who are
calling out this bs and be on their side
and say everything they want elon musk
is also the guy who's up running tesla
plants in in china or whatever praising
china on chinese social media that
pretty sure we'll check into that but so
i i don't i don't necessarily care for
the the crazy idea because
what he's doing is good for freedom good
for personal responsibility you're never
going to agree with someone 100 and the
thing about elon is he j when you hear
him talk especially about ai and stuff
he seems genuinely concerned about the
fate of humanity and where we're going
so i it might be genuine yeah i mean i
was saying this
when we were in nashville and
the story about elon even discussing
buying twitter first broke i am
optimistic in some ways i'm also
cautious you know i'm not like a giant
elon fan but i have liked what he's been
saying and i'm gonna take the evil i
don't know over the evil i know because
the people currently running that
website are absolutely terrible so i i
want to give the guy the benefit of the
doubt here but who knows he i mean
we should consider all possibilities
elon musk
flanks
the liberty side saying everything they
want to hear oh yeah the epstein stuff
how come no one's talking about that oh
look at these leftist organizations
trying to shut us down and then
everyone's like yes and really you're
just buying into this thing
it's too based and what are your gripes
with elon um so some of what tim talked
about with him having plants in china
it's not just that though my point isn't
that i actively dislike him it's just
that i i don't really know him or his
agenda well enough at this point to say
i'm a big fan or that i trust him i'm a
big fan i'm a big dude's building
starship starlink those are awesome yeah
i'm yeah and i'm certain
awesome i'm a fan of a lot of the stuff
he's doing i think i don't actively
dislike him like i said i'm very
cautiously optimistic about what he's
doing here i like the things that he's
doing but i don't want to quite sign up
for the you know elon bandwagon very
concerned
sir i'm i'm very cool with everything
elon is doing for the most part you take
a look at uh jeremy's razors they they
make their razors in china i believe and
a lot of people got angry and jeremy
explained to us as jeremy boring co-ceo
of daily wire
you can't make these things here like it
doesn't happen so they they tried right
and so it's like if we raise enough
money absolutely we're gonna open a
plant here and and do everything and um
in charge three times more for the
razors because there won't be slaves
making them that's and that's true too
and then you've got elon musk praising
china the way i see it is
i'm not as concerned about this my
concern is intent and what he's working
on so
take a look at us for instance here we
are on youtube knowing we can't talk
about the fisa data release do we not do
the show and have zero reach on any of
these topics or do we say okay we're
gonna do what we can with the platforms
we have and then try and find
alternatives elon musk is doing so much
good
yes he's got you know praise for china
are planned in china
but i'm wondering what the total weight
is going to be if it's like 60 doing
really good things fixing things and
then 40 percent is in the bad area i'm
like it's not absolute no you got to
weigh the good with the bed and i would
agree with you on that too i would
absolutely agree the one thing about
musk that i really do like and i've
mentioned this before is the fact that
he seems to be at least in his rhetoric
very pro-human and also not just in his
rhetoric and his behavior he has quite a
lot of children the man believes that
human life is a good thing he warns
against the birth dearth or the fact
that we're going to experience serious
consequences from being under-populated
and so he's trying to encourage people
to have more children i think those are
all great things doesn't that sound
weird though he's got like seven of them
doesn't well no i mean does he he's
gonna i just think it's weird for him to
come out and be like overpopulations of
myth it's like that's a little too on
the nose you know yeah i don't know i
just think every other billionaire on
the planet and really every member of
that kind of elite class says the exact
opposite it's fantastic to have a voice
who's bill gates is telling the truth
about it he's still spreading lies bill
gates came out and was dragging elon and
he was like
i think he's going to make it worse the
billionaires are fighting
but you know 25. that's really annoying
the annoying thing about bill gates is
he's just such a
evil person
you know he's he's the kind of guy who's
sitting there he's talking in this
interview about censorship he's the kind
of guy who would be like i don't
understand why poor people have messy
homes just have your maid clean
everything for you and your butler can
bring you your scotch did he actually
say that no okay i'm making a joke okay
the point is he says we shouldn't allow
people to have open communication on the
internet and it's like yeah you're a
rich dude who can do whatever you want
and you don't want the poor people to
have access to their rights of speech i
get it that's the annoying thing it's
this vapid elitist like why don't you
just have the help clean your floors
because people don't have help they have
to do it themselves but he's this rich
guy who's like why would anyone want
disinformation dude you are not the
arbiter of truth and morality you're
some dude who sold software you are also
not a healthy person either and then he
complained get this he said is elon
going to allow covet vaccine
misinformation twitter just censored new
breaking information
because of your stupid policies so sit
down and shut up you have no idea what
you're talking about old man you don't
think he's a good health man i was i was
thinking about trying the the bill gates
diet i want to figure out what he's
eating well you let your gut get really
huge yeah make sure your neck is
sticking forward and then uh hug
yourself a lot when you're nervous
i think that'll get you right to where
bill's at right now bill heal up man if
all we get from elon musk is this meme
elon musk has done the ultimate good
it is his neck bill fix your posture get
it back
so he writes in case you need to lose a
boner fast and it's bill gates and then
next to it is the pregnant man emoji but
can i just point out how str how strange
it is that bill gates is wearing a blue
shirt like the pregnant man with a big
gut
man but the haircut the haircut's the
same same haircut
no glasses though
we're not overpopulated by the way the
people are just male aligned at the
moment we have too many people in these
small pockets of cities with not enough
rail we it's hard to get food from the
farm to the city but if we have like low
orbit drone transfer we have we could
have like easily 17 billion people on
this planet did you see the slingshot
they made for orbit launching where it's
like
it's this um tube and they put something
in it and then it spins around like
crazy and then that's what i'm talking
about okay so you use you can put an
underground track where you have a
magnet push it so it goes up and then
you kick on the propellers and take it
the rest of the way it spins really
really fast and then just momentum will
get you into orbit yeah it's it's an
orbit launching and you can catch things
like that from other planets when you
you slingshot it towards the other
planet the other thing catches you and
then slows you down
and then you're crazy sounds really
uncomfortable imagine imagine if farmers
were like we got a latest shipment of
corn and they put it in this thing that
spins it and flings it in outer space
and then it lands and loads by the time
you got it it would be popcorn
yeah no it wouldn't why would it just
get so much heat you're shaking it up
the fall set it up yeah you use
propellers
no no no we're coming back into the
attack on fire i think you gotta use ion
thrusters in in the stratosphere to
guide it and then once it gets out of
the stratosphere again you or you press
ion thrusters from above to push it back
down and then you kick the propellers
back on to slowly bring it in
if it's lightweight enough the friction
won't destroy it i when i saw the meme
that elon posted about bill gates and
the pregnant man i just i couldn't
understand because even that he knows we
all could be wrong we all hate bill kay
i mean all the conservatives the one
billionaire they're like no is bill
gates they're even okay with jeff bezos
but this was because bill gates shorted
tesla and he said i can't take your
questions
he's got he's got a 500 million short
position and elon said i can't take your
climate change activism seriously if you
have a short against the company doing
the most to fight climate change
i look at this meme and i'm like it's
like they made a cartoon to bill gates
yeah it's true hasn't made a cartoon of
him yeah um elon musk i have to say that
i definitely admire him because he's one
of the only voices that i've heard being
actively pro-human not pro-life as such
but being very like we need to bring up
the birth rate kids are very important
he does have seven i think he has seven
kids by a bunch of different ladies but
he's doing his part like he's not like
pre not practicing what he preaches well
you think it's better to have seven kids
with a multiple wives i think it's
better to breathe
well i think i think it's better to
bring uh seven children into the world
with one woman i think that would be the
ideal life for those kids but if you are
going to tell people to have a bunch of
babies then you should be doing the same
you know with a bunch of women
i don't know about that i mean who's the
father who who's fathering these kids
who's mother
who's mothering these kids where are the
kids at are they at their moms or their
eli i think that he had fun i think he's
probably got a lot of help yeah he
hasn't well so i've hired people to
raise his kids i don't think these and i
agree with you that it's not good to
have much different kids it's definitely
not but that's yeah i hear you're on
that but that's why i say it's better to
have seven kids with one lady yeah he's
not ideal but lydia's i mean he
practices what he preaches right he's
like
a hundred women with a hundred hundred
kids
you would have a hundred babies walk
away and not even have to think about it
how great life would that would be for
my wild animal what is elon doing that i
don't know he has seven kids with
different women well i just wanted yeah
i just want to say this
how disturbing is it that
it's refreshing to us to hear one of the
most powerful people in the world say
that they don't think there should be
fewer humans right he's probably the
only billionaire that thinks that
because many of them are like futurists
and they're like everything's bad thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm we'll see
you all there